ich bin extra nach hamburg gereist um
hier das beste hotel des ganzen landes
zu testen einige von euch kennen das
wahrscheinlich schon aus diversen reihen
[Musik]
willkommen im fairmont hotel vier
jahreszeiten in hamburg
[Musik]
[Applaus]
hallo mein tag ich habe eine nacht
ok empfangen wie gewohnt schon mal aber
erste klasse aber wie sieht das zimmer
aus
okay okay wir haben zwei räume
anscheinend
[Musik]
na dann
wie ich es mir schon gedacht habe ist
das hotel tatsächlich wieder in einem
klassischen stil aber das hat auch einen
grund das hotel gibt es seit 1897 und
fast alle nobel hotels bestechen er
durch eine klassische als eine moderne
einrichtung eines immer hier mehr so
wohnbereichen arbeitsbereich und
fernseher und eine kleine teeküche
zweiter raum schlafzimmer hier auf der
rechten seite die mini bat die
unheimlich gut ausgestattet ist
tiroler red bull rotwein also wirklich
so eine krasse minibar die so gut
ausgestattet ist habe ich noch nie
gesehen wieder ein fernseher tatsächlich
sehe ich da vorne dass das zimmer einen
balkon angeschlossen hat das bett sieht
unheimlich bequem aus da freue ich mich
schon das testen zu können aber was mich
am meisten umgehauen hat ist dass wir
einen begehbaren kleiderschrank direkt
an unsere zimmer angeschlossen haben
alfred direkt neben dem begehbaren
kleiderschrank finden wir das badezimmer
das sieht sehr gut aus und das sieht
sehr sauber aus als wären wir natürlich
gleich wieder mit uv lampe testen und
vom badezimmer über das schlafzimmer
über das wohnzimmer finden wir den
zugang zum persönlichen
balkon
weiß ich nehme das thema jetzt erstmal
auf camera ein bisschen unter die lupe
um euch ein bisschen mehr erzählen zu
können tatsächlich ist das zimmer aber
gar nicht das was dieses hotel ausmacht
sondern der service wie immer und vor
allem das essen es gibt mehrere
möglichkeiten wo und liebliche essen
können eine davon zwei sterne restaurant
nicht im bestand das bett zu testen
einrichtung schon gut aber wie sieht es
mit der sauberkeit aus des brenners also
das letzte luxushotel das ich getestet
habe hatte ja so seine kleinen
problemchen drei griffe dreimal staub
gefunden wie sie zum besten hotel
deutschlands aus meistens merkt man
schon auf den ersten blick ob irgendwas
nicht besonders sauber ist zb an den
glasflächen oder hier soll neben den
lampen so horst haben wir aber gar nicht
also auf den ersten blick wirkt komplett
sauber wie sieht es aber auf den zweiten
blick aus wir starten auf den bildern
ganz ganz leichter staub aber das kann
tatsächlich wollte morgen geputzt sein
und so ein bisschen staub kann richtig
über den tag wieder kommt auf den
fernseher auch hier minimaler staub aber
auch hier würde ich sagen es ist
vollkommen okay tatsächlich habe ich
mich nämlich noch mal ein bisschen
besser informiert und herausgefunden
dass so super weißer staub quasi tages
staub ist und desto dunkler wird desto
länger lebten dort und desto mehr es ist
das hier ist super weniger super weiß er
ist wahrscheinlich seit dem letzten
putzen einfach wieder hin gekommen es
ist einfach ein bisschen staub im raum
der ist nicht vermeidbar
[Musik]
sauberkeit der zimmer lässt keine
wünsche offen aber wie sieht es in der
königsdisziplin im badezimmer aus und
tatsächlich vermute ich dass es super
sauber ist denn im bad weil die
klobrille hochgeklappt so als seien aber
lieber gast herzlich willkommen in
deinem zimmer wir waren gerade hier drin
und haben alles sauber gemacht ob man
das jetzt offen lässt oder nicht dass
muss man hotellier fragen aber er ist
hochgeklappt um das heißt jemand hat
dort geburt natürlich verlassen uns aber
nicht auf unser bauchgefühl sondern wir
haben die uv lampe dabei jetzt geht's ab
ins bad die königs ist okay die sehen
dieses super clean aus die ist gar
nichts ins waschbecken drum herum und im
waschbecken ist eben so gar nichts am
lenkrad bei den produkten wie
hingestellt werden die hat ja definitiv
jemand vorher in der hand gehabt aber
vermutlich mit handschuhen denn hier ist
auch nichts der föhn auch komplett clean
und jetzt die toilette mal genau
hingucken die toilette an sich ist
komplett clean also das habe ich
wirklich noch in keinem hotel gehabt
auch um die toilette drum herum ist
alles sauber macht die dusche sauber
sauber sauber sauber sauber sauber boden
sauber also bisher mit abstand das thema
das ich getestet habe natürlich fange
ich jetzt nicht weil ich hier im hotel
bin und die möglichkeit habe an mit
sport arbeite ich hätte die möglichkeit
und so sieht der sport & spa bereich aus
[Musik]
weiß was aber nicht so es ist mein handy
ist leer und geht nicht mehr ich habe
keine ladekabel dabei und deswegen
können wir jetzt perfekt den service des
hotels testen angeblich soll es in
solchen hotelservice meist ich keine
grenzen geben deswegen 50 unten an und
werde schnell erfragen ob es möglich ist
ob sie iphone ladekabel da haben spitze
vielen vielen dank
[Musik]
das tatsächlich funktioniert
die haben einfach nur ich habe mir
gerade mal die minibar preise angeschaut
und ich bin aus allen wolken gefallen
meiner meinung nach egal was für ein
restaurant was für ein hotel du bist du
kannst keine san pellegrino
mineralwasser
0,25 liter für sechs euro 50 verkaufen
das ist unverschämt und no job so bei
wasser das übersteigt alles das ist ein
liter preis von 26 euro dass das geht
nicht das noae teuer ist das neue handys
wie teuer ist die man auch hier alle in
der minibar wiederfindet klar kein
problem des absoluter luxus aber wasser
mit einem literpreis von 26 euro ist
unverschämt egal wo man ist
mittlerweile ist dunkel geworden es wäre
zeit abend zu essen es gibt allerdings
ein problem das zwei sterne restaurant
restaurant airline dass es hier im hotel
gibt hat sonntags und montags komplett
geschlossen ein weiteres restaurant das
nicht hinein ist leider heute abend
komplett ausgebucht also werde ich wohl
oder übel auf den room service
zurückgreifen müssen ist kein problem
ist sogar eigentlich ganz gut dann könnt
ihr das nämlich mit dem brenners
vergleich zum guten abend ich würde
gerne etwas zu essen bestellen da haben
jahreszeiten grillsachen
hotel vier jahreszeiten bürger und ein
bisher da bin ich mir ein bisschen
unschlüssig was würden sie empfehlen
ok dann gerne den cheesecake super ich
danke lieferzeit anscheinend 20 bis 30
minuten wenn das klappt dann wäre das
für mich sehr beeindruckend denn ich
hab' vorspeise hauptspeise und dessert
[Musik]
es ist ein kompletter wird all das was
hier auf diesem tisch steht ist für mich
wir haben zur vorspeise den salat wir
haben zur hauptspeise den burger mit
pommes die vermutlich hier sind und zur
nachspeise den new york cheesecake krank
[Musik]
und jetzt wird gegessen also
wenn ich sie morgens ich habe sehr gut
geschlafen und jetzt kommt ein frühstück
[Musik]
das war eine nacht im besten hotel
deutschlands und das ist mein fazit das
zimmer war cool ich hatte im endeffekt
zwei zimmer ein ankleidezimmer ein
großes bad und auch noch den balkon also
für eine alleinreisende person
eigentlich viel zu krass an sich die
einrichtung eigentlich auch ganz schön
man muss halt auf das klassische stehen
ich würde dem ganzen vier von fünf gehen
service ließ so ein bisschen zu wünschen
übrig ich habe vorher angerufen und habe
gesagt dass ich gerne das zimmer nur von
halben tag buchen will weil ich gerne
daran drehen möchte daraufhin wurde mir
mehrfach gesagt das nicht möglich sei
ich musste es für den ganzen tag buchen
und dann wussten die leute im hotel
schon dass ich komme und dass ich das
hotel testen werde und das fanden die
gar nicht so witzig das habe ich gefühlt
auch so ein bisschen gemerkt auf der
anderen seite waren die leute die
natürlich nicht wussten wer ich bin oder
was ich da mache super nett zu mir und
haben im prinzip mir den wunsch von den
lippen abgelesen ich konnte anrufen
iphone ladekabel bestellt essen aufs
zimmer essen zur richtigen zeit und so
weiter all in all würdig dem eine 3 von
15.15 wenn man meine eigene situation
betrachtet und 5 und 5 wenn man den
allgemeinen service betrachtet die
verpflegung konnte ich nicht ganz
ausreichen so wie ich es gerne gemacht
hätte und wie ich gerne getestet hätten
hier kommt auch wieder das servicing so
ein bisschen zum tragen konnte ich das
nicht testen waren alle restaurants
geschlossen weil ich angerufen habe und
beide keine lust hatten dass sich dort
filmen wollte oder weil sie wirklich
geschlossen wenn es wirklich so wäre
dass sie auf den sonntag alle
restaurants geschlossen hätten dann
finde ich das schon wirklich merkwürdig
und das würde punktabzug ansonsten das
essen war ein absoluter traum das
frühstück war supergut und abends ist
erst einmal auch sehr gut aber der preis
ist natürlich hab ich damit zum preis
aber erst später kommen mit anbetracht
dass die restaurants geschlossen hatten
und man irgendwie nicht so richtig dran
gekommen ist liegt das essen von mir
eine 3,5 von fünf das essen an sich war
gut die möglichkeiten jetzt abends dann
noch schnell auf schnell schnell im
restaurant zu kommen waren sehr schlecht
deswegen kein halb von 5 laura kalt war
absolut top notch ich habe ja in der
rückhand noch ein paar andere hotel
tests und ich habe dort auch immer
wieder mehr sachen gesehen die mich zum
einen erschrocken oder begeistert haben
dieses hotel war mit abstand das beste
so viel kann ich schon mal vorweg nehmen
wirklich ein absoluter traum da brauche
ich gar nicht länger darum herumreden
sauberkeit 5 und 5 tage direkt an der
innen als dafür die leute die sich in so
ein hotel einbuchen die perfekte lage
rolex wempe und diese ganzen teuren
läden sind direkt außenrum 55 der preis
ich habe natürlich nicht das kleinste
zimmer gut genauso wie im brenners habe
ich mich für so ein mittleres zimmer
entschieden und bin im endeffekt bei den
650 euro umgekommen das schmerzt das ist
unglaublich viel geld und ich habe mich
auch während des hotel tests dafür
entschieden nicht mehr weiter solche
hotels zu testen das ist im prinzip
immer das gleiche und das geld lohnt
sich nicht zumindest aus meiner sicht
preis oder preis-leistung kriegt von mir
1 kor 5 von 5 sternen es geht hier um
absoluten luxus und wenn man absoluten
luxus haben will dann sind das eben die
anlaufstellen es gibt keine andere
möglichkeit für mich allerdings trotzdem
preis oder preis-leistung 1 5 von 5
sternen wenn ich das video gefallen hat
was wir gerne ein leichter vergessen ich
den kanal zu abonnieren und mit dieses
jahr noch zu 500.000 abonnenten zu
verhelfen am sonntag kommt das nächste
video rechtsfolge rolex trade up sogar
ein video das ist extra aus portugal
gedreht habe mit rafa bekommen dann
sehen wir uns wieder macht's gut